gonna be so cool slow down wait for me
to get your present you can just back
time up we'll have to test you now to
make sure Chloe is like pretty selfish
but kids got the guns yeah is everybody
armed an Arcadia Bay now only the ones
who shouldn't be like step dildo like
you I'm not in the revolution yet Jay
you are the revolution max so we should
figure out how to best use and abuse
your power with the test well what's the
testing me sab dodge these bullets and
then ride yourself so you're no longer
shot now go find us five bottles three
please five bottles from where don't
break it you idiot oh gosh you suck
haha let's stand on the crane yeah we go
over here this looks like a graffiti
museum for Khloe and Rachel I bet I can
find out more about Rachel here bottle
do it orly if you break this one I'm
really not up to music Oh only three
bottles left oh this one hey honey
they're fake whoops hey don't you like a
cell phone is just talk about finding a
bottle in a haze there there's no hey
that looks exactly like this thing go
from my tornado vision oh yeah let's go
dogs go cuddle it spirit is low weights
that dough is the perfect photo op it
won't be in the photo it's a vampire
Devon Pardo I wonder if Chloe thinks
about her father when she looks at all
these smashed up cars because as he was
the Incredible Hulk okay what William
crush hahaha thanks max you're serious
about this we're gonna shoot all these
bottles without wasting a single bullet
aimie [ __ ] are right sir yes sir oh
yes did you see that [ __ ] max duh yeah
it was so [ __ ] cool I want to get
creative no but I found you a list total
[ __ ] bottle left yes the thing you'll
top let's take out this wheel rim on
your left is taking out the wheel rim
now hella yet you are welcome how about
using that junker for a target now
someone's gonna get shot goodbye cruel
bumper oh good ship it gun it was the
gun this world damn the gun I was gonna
take the whole of those haha max your
nose don't take it so yeah I don't feel
soo soo look controller well quickly
lion times before i go heart Kentucky's
number one time power so much you
freaked me out there do you feel any
better now a little thanks for helping
me ok looks like you're ready to lock
and load oh just step dad and she's
holding a guy Stellman Louise we both
need money in fact you need it so bad
you owe me a shitload don't you Chloe
huh you'll get your money don't they all
say that you know even when they're
broke and acting tough what are you
hiding there girlie let me see
where did you get that bracelet a friend
it's none of your god I races bracelet
you're my business now Rachel's bracelet
why the [ __ ] are you wearing her
bracelet calm yourself all right it was
a gift no it was it you stole that [ __ ]
give it to me right now [ __ ] you
better step back before you regret it
girl I mean it you want me to cut you
[ __ ] please please step back you're
kidding put that down shrim donington
shoots shoot for the love of God come on
girlie shoot me he literally asked you
to you BAM oh did you guys you're more
like Abbott and Costello ah that's all
right rewind eesh I'll consider this
interest on your loan ok I was probably
the more sensible course interest on the
lawyers you happen to shoot my date to
pay me or I'll track you down with this
interest have a good play kids reverse
reverse I really see was a banker here
we go yeah what time to do some killing
dilly dilly dilly dilly Doo and shoot Oh
arias oh man euless left I'll remember
you kid I'll remember you almost shot me
and you wish I had no memory because I
never forget to kill I'm glad there was
no bullets and they can just rewind time
in your hand and stick that barrel right
up Frank's ass you have the power gross
that's this week it's don't misplace the
dumbest place in the world don't know
railroad tracks always make me feel
better something about that impending
doom thing travelling movement the sound
of the train whistle it look at the beat
poet hear the noise of the rails you are
the blast of the horn stop being afraid
the Yale to get out of the way the
crunch of the tray the red mist oh no
time get a shot of the toys year we've
done nothing about this for you
no no no no I seem bigger what what
uh-oh here comes the train what it oh he
could take me off the train oh [ __ ] take
your boot off take your damn boot off
where's the helpful squirrel it's like
oh this switching lemma pull the lever
pull the lover oh my geez bucks move it
an inch awesome I think looks locked uh
here we go I better find the tool to cut
o God's sake whoops he's your teeth
crowbar crowbar hey let's use that to uh
take I can definitely use this bad boy
yeah let's let's think about that for a
while that's all you're here oh crap
crap crap shop I can't from orovalle
alright well
Oh
oh yeah pixie dying right now yeah yeah
she's dead you need to figure this out
all right mind yeah a guy good cool hey
shake that we need I can pull a total
MacGyver run run run max save your
friend Oh push push this damn something
is blocked Oh wrong damn it it's a brick
nice thing roebuck fantasies pretty good
right I have to help lift Chloe up John
oh Jesus
Oh
I guess we had a couple of choices you
okay I got splinters in my ass and legs
so I wish there was a less violent way
for you to save me and now the trains
can't get to Laurel oops aren't you glad
I took you away to fancies live with
them is cool yeah let's live with them
gonna do that again yeah I have to get
back to school before my next class
since you're the mist oh yes let's stay
on the train traffic great idea
companion we're almost ours I might not
last Chloe that's ok we will forever
sure hope Kate's ok oh you happy like no
drastic Ephesus class so I can do some
wandering hey Warren are you okay you
look thoughtful yet confused Maxwell's
silver hammer perfect timing I need help
with this chemical experiment perfect
asking me for help means you're screwed
have that either a bit of potassium or
sodium it's up to you to decide dr. max
all right go deal she pundit Goudy great
great choice were spread chucks no it's
not shut up warned you don't now spoken
saudi ever it is boom max was dead all
right maybe that would just remove her
pirates yeah zip what was she gonna say
like a pun up guys is it maybe she's
gonna like hit on him slightly and say
that a see'em be correctly I think
that's it what he's gonna say that asks
you yeah i'm not sure why you're letting
me decide Oh Boris go go Tessie I see
potassium it you'll be this works you
get it that actually makes a little more
sense yeah it does yeah we've got a hug
handle whoa gum powdered science now
boom head is the table haha OSP teacher
hi miss grant funny I was just thinking
about you lies I'll believe you I like
the way you look like you're always
thinking ahead you have no idea you miss
grant can I ask you a possibly dumb
science question you know my stock
teacher answer there are no dumb
questions asked Polly that's not true
would you at least a teacher or so
you're David chemical mix for this
week's experiment neither unless you
want a face full of powder i would add
chlorine chlorine love liza that's you
actually think you should use a lot yes
yes [ __ ] kill Warren won't become a
scientist yet what can I do hahaha going
going gone oh yes think that you Derek
she blinded me with science Laurieann
you idiot wrong Warren you need to add
chlorine not potassium or sodium
chlorine I didn't think of that can
argue with a confident scientist and you
let's try it that's definitely a noxious
gas hey Laurie yes audience that's
literally won't be so noises dr.
Caulfield quick ticket fun of him dying
the bounds of science drink it drink it
drink it drink it drink it drink it
drink it every year cuz I maybe don't
understand my position oh okay you don't
understand mine oh don't be such a whiny
honey please leave me alone but not take
it later hey wait for me it's just not
leave her alone
let's walk with her everything hey pal
stop don't come near me come you you say
okay all right personal bodyguard sorry
to bother you mr. Jefferson I'm only
bothered when you avoid turning in
photos but you know this so what can I
do for you guys just between you and me
I'm worried about Kate Marsh kate is
with the video out man yes she can't do
homework while she's being tormented on
a daily basis what if Gabe brought this
on herself she means well but maybe she
doth protest too much she seems like
she's holding back the truth have you
talked to her no I will she's mad I
missed her call today I just don't want
Kate Marsh to become the next Rachel
amber Rachel amber what does she have to
do with Kate with all her missing
persons posters around it's hard not to
think of her I miss rachel too but think
about her skis behind it Purdy's the
banyo am said happened in the bathroom I
was a private conversation not that I
wouldn't tell you this is a serious
accusation max so you don't believe me I
would never make something like this up
I hope so max but it's easy to point
fingers if mr. Matson claims you might
be a pot dealer as he did should I
believe him listen should I excuse me
max Wow hello did not go so well
okay why is David taking photos of Kate
now this is so wrong and weird that girl
is always just looking at stuff tell her
to watch out yeah come on oh god damn
get up love God oh whoa dang is for wide
time for some reason get up all right
can't we can't get out we have to do
something just handle it I guess what it
where they do what up max hey Warren can
you help me out of this chair I feel
happy to be stuck he can you tell her to
just watch out got a duck and go change
into okay Oh some crazy [ __ ] is going
down with the girls dorm Zachary do not
come into my class like that ever again
listen everybody remain seated great
great power bro that was missed oh no
she's gonna jump what oh god is she is
she Oh No
she can't die she can't Wow okay that
ain't real dark all right well we don't
seem to be able to get back to ma not
now I have to try something I won't be
able to rewind again and again I don't
think we can save her maybe that's it
has he made the wrong choices what can
we do uh oh it's like that bitter
futurama though when he drinks too much
coffee it's exactly like I've cough
cough cough cough cough cough cough
cough coverage keep going oh so we're
just walking through there Kim frozen
time all right so right we need to dry
ice underneath her or climb up the steps
yeah yes time grab grab go get her oh
god now you're gonna get blamed for
pushing you aren't you oh no no okay
okay forget what your nose later Go Go
what are you doing here Mac stop don't
come near me hot now it won't work I
don't have any power now I have to do
this by myself oh well seriously don't
come near me I will jump alright okay
alright okay I'll Billups this camp
right here decision time mm-hmm how much
changes in my pocket god damn it I know
you want to help me I love that you're
stepped in to David but it doesn't
matter now nothing matters you matter
and not just to me I do want to believe
that hey Simon your life is still yours
let me help all right you are such a
liar you want to help by ignoring Mike I
didn't hear a ring I was with Chloe my
phone no phone died is wrong she'll see
through that it was in silent mode could
work I thought it was Warren why don't
you look at your phone I was with Khloe
the only care about I just feel like
you're like lying st. was in silent mode
Oh God risk wait White Lies silent mode
and I didn't see it or I totally would
have answered I needed you to answer max
everybody thinks of a viral [ __ ] now
there is no everybody there's only your
friends and your family who love you
Kate please trust me come stand by me
okay I can help you now I know I can
this morning I erased the web link to
the video it was written on the shower
room mirror that's your story now how
can I trust you what about this morning
when I needed help you told me to do
nothing hey I'm gathering proof that
Nathan Prescott drugged you and you're
not the only victim you do have my back
Mac that's the first time I felt hopeful
in a week alright nailed it all need to
have each other's backs so I want you to
come with me now please you don't have
to do this max I'm in a nightmare and I
can't wake up unless I put myself to
sleep then everybody at blackwell
compose pics of my body horny on the
Internet forever no wonder they call it
a web nothing can ever get out like my
video I wish you could go back in time
and erase everything there are billions
of videos no be strong no everybody will
forget be strong Oh everyone will forget
your cold pal uh nobody cares Kate don't
be another viral Victoria video in a day
and everybody will forget you can't
scrub my video from the internet and
that's how he'll be remembered unless
like Oh Oh Kate you can't do this to all
the people who care about you know
nobody cares about that was wrong nobody
whoopsie daisies your mother oh don't
see her an cuz she's a jerk your father
or your mother oh good I think the first
thing to say is your mother what about
your mother Kate you'll destroy her she
doesn't care about a video she loves you
you don't know my mother at all damn she
already thinks Satan has me on the fast
track to hell let's prove it oh god no
oh [ __ ] oh oh wow is that an
irreversible decision um Wow there you
go maybe that was always gonna happen
kini this is no way to save her I think
there's a way to save her you probably
should have answered that phone call you
just can't believe it I actually don't
think I would have changed her being a
little roof watching her drop like a
weight I really thought I could save her
like a superhero come on max do not for
a second blame yourself Lauren I don't
mean to sound weird but there's
something ominous going on at blackwell
today proves that and i'm working on
proof that Kate Marsh is connected to
Rachel amber somehow along with Nathan
and mr. Madsen I'm not a big conspiracy
guy but I wouldn't doubt it Nathan did
scare me yesterday and Madson is a
straight up [ __ ] so what do you
think is really happening what the hell
is this
the weather confirms this weird day I
feel that Jew max there was no eclipse
scheduled today I would know I would
another good song yeah I believe you
weren't
I believe anything this week
I
so even the background of the the main
game has changed like the starts their
life is dark life is a clique is eclipse
yet no more life although that
lighthouse finally getting some use
before it gets smashed to pieces in a
day's time Wow so am I feel like we had
mixed results a girl died it's never a
good thing death I'm not saying this
sign of a good job a job well done but
we we get the option to make decisions
and then we get to the option to change
those decisions and all of those
decisions led to the death of a lady
which I think maybe says something about
us well maybe we shouldn't be allowed to
make any decisions in life if yeah I
think that's true yeah yeah maybe it's
but also because we haven't ever had to
make such decisions in all I know like
choosing whether or not to answer a
phone call I do that all the time I know
what if people are dying I have a 30
room for that which is cameron's don't
answer alright and you're still here for
now I'm saying that my own that decision
didn't necessarily cause Kate's jump off
the roof I don't know I feel like if we
have out to the phone then we might have
been been able to although she did buy a
lie about being on silent yeah that
wasn't yeah we did share it was like an
I think it was the mother man I think
the mother like what about your mother
I'm like well I missed out for my mom to
say I think if I hate you mother good
call on the arm but I think maybe you
know the arm and the parents are too
closely tied i would have gone well for
a brother brother or sister yeah and
then even then it was a pity her sister
she would have compared herself to her
sister like my sister she's so good at
getting a brother yeah could maybe be
like a foursome cross you know so yeah I
can split everything yes we play which
we could which we definitely should it
something this is why we did so badly
because we're too good with two good cam
with we are good characters and what we
needed to be was jerks to save people's
lives sometimes you need to tell lies ya
know like in the one live we did in hell
but the phone was actually good a good
call i think you're right i think maybe
the moral of the story here is the lie
you should always lie always lie never
tell the truth I'm glad we got to the
bottom of their people
wonderful life really is challenged
you